so I'm a climate scientist and if this
room is representative of the country we
live in that means about 60% of you so
maybe from about there over don't
strongly trust me for information on the
causes of climate change now I promise
to tell the truth tonight but just to
humor that demographic I've started this
talk with a falsehood this statement was
not made by President Obama was actually
made by President Reagan and it wasn't
about climate change and the Paris
climate Accord it was actually about the
Montreal Protocol and stratospheric
ozone depletion now I'm sure that many
of you are familiar with this
environmental problem but you should be
because it's a rare environmental
success story and it's worth revisiting
because sometimes we need to examine the
world we've avoided in order to find
guidance for the choices we make today
so let's go back to the 1970s when some
questionable choices were made first of
all who hairstyles second of all
objectively terrible quantities of
hairspray and third CFCs
chlorofluorocarbons man-made chemicals
that were used as propellant in aerosol
spray cans and as he it turns out these
CFCs were a problem because they were
destroying the ozone layer now I'm sure
most of you have heard of the ozone
layer but why does it matter well quite
simply the ozone layer is Earth's
sunscreen and it's really fragile if you
could take all of the ozone which is
mostly about ten to twenty miles up
above our heads and compress it down to
the surface of the earth it would form a
thin shell only about two pennies thick
about an eighth of an inch
and that Finn shell does an amazing
amount of work though it it filters out
more than 90% of the harmful UV
radiation coming from the Sun and while
I'm sure many of you enjoy that Sun tan
that you get from the remaining 10% it
causes a lot of problems
cataracts damage to crops damage to
immune systems and also skin cancer it's
not an exaggeration to say that a threat
to the ozone layers a threat to human
safety and actually ironically it was
human safety that motivated the
invention of CFCs in the first place you
see in the early days of refrigeration
refrigerators use toxic and flammable
chemicals like propane and ammonia for
good reason the refrigeration industry
wanted a safe alternative and they found
that in 1928 when a scientist named
Thomas Midgley synthesized the first
commercially viable CFCs and in fact
Midgley famously inhaled CFCs and blew
out a candle to demonstrate at a
scientific conference that they were
safe and non flammable and in fact as a
scientist I can tell you there is no way
you could get away with that kind of
antic today
I mean Wow but but really at the time
CFCs were a really remarkable invention
they allowed what we now know is modern
day refrigeration and air conditioning
and other things so it wasn't actually
until over 40 years later in the 1970s
when scientists realized that CFCs would
break down high in the atmosphere and
damage the ozone layer and this finding
really set off a lot of public concern
it led ultimately to the banning of CFC
usage in aerosol spray cans in the US
and a few other countries in 1978 now
the story doesn't end there because CFCs
were used in much more than just spray
cans in 1985 scientists discovered the
Antarctic ozone hole and this was a
truly alarming discovery
science scientists did not expect this
at all
before the Antarctic ozone hole
scientists expected maybe a 5 or 10
percent reduction in ozone over a
century but what they found over the
course of less than a decade was that
more than a third of the ozone had
simply vanished over an area larger than
the size of the US and although we now
know that CFCs are the root cause of
this ozone hole at the time the science
was far from settled yet despite this
uncertainty the crisis helped spur
nations to act so that quote that I
started this talk with about the
Montreal Protocol from President Reagan
that was his signing statement when he
signed the Montreal Protocol after its
unanimous ratification by the US Senate
and this is something that's truly worth
celebrating in fact yesterday was the
30th anniversary of the Montreal
Protocol
[Applause]
because of the protocol ozone-depleting
substances are now declining in our
atmosphere and we're starting to see the
first signs of healing in the ozone
layer and furthermore because many of
those ozone depleting substances are
also very potent greenhouse gases the
Montreal Protocol has actually delayed
global warming by more than a decade
that's just wonderful but I think it's
worth asking the question as we face our
current environmental crisis global
warming what lessons can we learn from
Montreal
are there any I think there are first we
don't need absolute certainty to act
when Montreal is signed we were less
certain then of the risks from CFCs than
we are now of the risks from greenhouse
gas emissions a common tactic that
people who oppose climate action use is
to completely ignore risk and focus only
on uncertainty but so what about
uncertainty we do we make decisions in
the face of uncertainty all the time
literally all the time you know I bet
those of you who drove here tonight you
probably wore your seatbelt and so ask
yourself did you wear your seatbelt
because someone told you with a hundred
percent uncertainty that you would get
in a car crash on the way here probably
not so that's the first lesson risk
management and decision making always
have uncertainty ignoring risk and
focusing only on uncertainty as a
distraction in other words in action is
an action second it takes a village to
raise a healthy environment the Montreal
Protocol wasn't just put together by
industry and governments or
environmental advocacy groups and
scientists it was put together by all of
them they all had a seat at the table
and they all played an important role in
the solution and I think in this regard
we're actually seeing some encouraging
signs today we see
not just environmental groups concerned
about climate change but also civic and
religious groups the military and
businesses so wherever you find yourself
on that spectrum we need you at the
table because if we're going to solve
global warming it's gonna take actions
at all levels from the individual to the
international and everything in between
third lesson don't let the perfect be
the enemy of the good
while Montreal has become the brake
pedal for stopping ozone depletion and
it's beginning it was more just like a
tap on the brakes it was actually the
later amendments to the protocol that
really marked the decision to hit the
brakes on ozone depletion so to those
who despair that the Paris climate
Accord didn't go far enough or that
you're limited actions on their own
won't solve global warming I say don't
let the perfect to be the enemy of the
good and finally I think it helps us to
contemplate the world we've avoided
indeed the world we have avoided by
enacting the Montreal Protocol is one of
catastrophic changes to our environment
into human well-being by the 2030s
we'll be avoiding millions of new skin
cancer cases per year with a number that
would only grow if I'm lucky I'll live
long enough to see the end of this
animation and to see the ozone hole
restored to its natural state so as we
write the story for Earth's climate
future for this century and beyond we
need to ask ourselves what will our
actions be so that someone can stand on
this stage in 30 or 50 or hundred years
to celebrate the world that they've
avoided thank you